is Kourtney Kardashian having a fling  with Justin Bieber or getting back  together with Scott Disick according to  our source neither Kourtney and the  Biebs were spotted out at the peppermint  Club Saturday night but a source close  to court tells et that Kourtney and  Bieber are not hooking up our source  says they did not leave the West  Hollywood hot spot together adding quote  they're in the same group of friends and  socialize together all the time  meanwhile there have been recent reports  that Kourtney and Scott Disick have  reconciled but our source says that's  not the case noting the friendly exits  have a wonderful relationship and enjoy  co-parenting their three kids  Mason Penelope and rein quote she's not  interested in being in a relationship  with anyone I have no idea it's in God's  hands